Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and Zack Snyder
just revealed the new Batmobile and Ben Affleck’s
Batsuit.
As expected, the suit gives off a very Dark
Knight Returns vibe.
He used his Leica M Camera to take the picture
so it’s Black and White.
But we know a few more facts, so this video
will be a breakdown of both the Suit and the
Car.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do DC Videos every week.
Normally they’d be on Wednesday’s because
of Arrow, but as you can see, Batman waits
for no one.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
leave me suggestions for bonus videos.
So first thing’s first.
This is the suit and the car that they’re
using in Superman VS Batman.
Batman is much older a la Ben Affleck’s
50 something Batman versus Christian Bale’s
30 something version of the character.
The suit itself reinforces the idea that they
adapted Frank Miller’s Dark Knight Returns
arc.
In that story Batman is way more jaded and
the world has gone to shit.
Obviously that’s not totally the case in
the world of the Man of Steel movies.
But Batman in this movie, is not going to
start out best buds with Henry Cavill.
So he’s bringing out the big guns.
Which is where this much more armored looking
suit and car comes from.
You can’t tell because it’s a black and
white photo, but the raised portions of the
suit are silver.
It’s silver plates on black tech fabric.
So they combined the defensive nature of Christian
Bale’s first suit with the modularity of
the second suit.
And made it a little shinier.
Here’s the suit from Frank Miller’s Dark
Knight Returns.
It’s really Ben Affleck’s ear pieces that
evoke the look.
This batman always reminded me of the Frank
Castle Punisher.
Just beating the crap out of villains.
Supposedly that’s going to be what the initial
meeting of Batman and Superman is going to
be in the Man of Steel sequel.
Batman sees what happened to Metropolis in
the wake of General Zod’s battle and armors
up appropriately.
Remember when that first movie came out, there
was a big conversation going on about the
amount of damage Superman and Zod did to Metropolis
during their fight.
It was like watching a little kid stomp through
a LEGO model.
They did hundreds of millions of dollars in
damage.
So if you were the world’s greatest detective
and the most cynical superhero on the planet.
What would you do?
You’d probably beef up your arsenal.
The Batmobile itself is a lot sleeker than
Christian Bale’s tumblr, which is funny,
because it looks more like a real car.
In the Dark Knight Returns comic, the batmobile
is basically a full on tank.
So it’s almost like Zack Snyder went in
the opposite direction.
I think it’s just to be more practical.
He’s going up against Superman, at least
during the first part of the movie.
So a tank wouldn’t really help him that
much, and it’s not fast.
At All.
He needs something smaller and quicker.
I’m really interested to find out what kind
of extra weaponry he’s developed.
They’re not completely throwing away all
the canon from Christopher Nolan’s Dark
Knight Trilogy, but they’re not really addressing
anything from those movies either.
I still consider Ben Affleck’s version of
the character to be the logical evolution
of Christian Bale’s character.
And we can’t forget the influence of Wonder
Woman and Cyborg.
The movie is going to be like a World’s
Finest version of Justice League.
Before the actual Justice League movie.
I think it’s going to take most of the movie
for the Trinity to come together, so I’m
really interested to see what their chemistry
is.
If you haven’t read DC Comics New 52 version
of Justice League, they essentially got Wonder
Woman and Superman together as a romantic
couple and even though they work together
now, when they first met, Batman pulled out
some kryptonite the first couple of times
he met Superman.
So don’t be surprised if Ben Affleck has
the famous Kryptonite Ring in the movie.
It would be a pretty sweet shout out to the
comics.
Before the new 52 reboot, historically, Batman
kept a Kryptonite ring in case Superman ever
went out of control.
They movie might deal with this in a more
practical way, but in the comics Superman
is highly vulnerable to magic and mind control.
So he’s been used by supervillains as a
smashy finger puppet on many occasions.
In this movie that’s not going to be the
case, and right now all we know about Lex
Luthor is that he’ll be a really young tech
billionaire.
People are calling it a darker version of
his Mark Zuckerberg character from Social
Network.
Take that with a grain of salt, but we’re
finally starting to get a look at the movie.
Which is awesome.
Regardless of what you think about Zack Snyder’s
movies, he’s always been really good about
giving fans an inside look.
I remember back at Comic Con 2008 he brought
the Owl Ship from Watchmen.
It was pretty badass.
They built it like a real ship, so don’t
be surprised if the Batmobile is at Comic
Con this year.
The cool thing about all the versions of the
car are that they actually drive.
Adam West’s batmobile was probably the closest
to just being a regular car.
When I was a little kid Michael Keaton’s
batmobile was badass, but the funny thing
is that I found out it weighed so much that
in real life it couldn’t go fast at all.
That all changed when Christopher Nolan built
the Tumblr and then eventually the Bat Pod
motorcycle.
They actually drove really well.
Those tires were huge, so they didn’t turn
super fast, but the tumblr was meant to be
an uban tank that could withstand a missile
blast.
I guess that the new batmobile has to be able
to withstand a superman, but logically the
only way to do that would be to give a coat
of Kryptonite Paint.
I haven’t see it in the comics but I guess
a Kryptonite field generator would be more
effective.
That’s really where Lex Luthor comes in,
I’m really interested to see how he deals
with Superman using modern day technology.
Zack Snyder has taken a much less comical
approach to the character, so I’m expecting
a more advanced version of Bruce Wayne’s
Secret Projects Department.
But now it’s your turn, let me know what
you think of the new suit and batmobile and
how you think it’s going to inform the movie.
Batman isn’t the type to make friends easily,
so watching them interact for the first time
is going to be a lot of fun.
In related news, if you haven’t seen there’s
a bunch of huge stuff happening this week
so I’m posting a few more videos than I
normally do.
We’re getting the first trailer for The
Flash tv show, agents of shield and arrow
both have their finales.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And I added a link to my video schedule down
in the description.
I’m crossing my fingers that I survive to
the weekend.
So pray for me.
Right now click here to learn more about the
Justice League movie and click here to learn
more about the Arrow finale and The Flash
Trailer.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!